I like throwing a curveball at the
beginning
um for both of you you've done so many
things in your careers what's the first
if someone has never seen anything that
you've done before what is the first
thing you'd like them watching and why
season five of the crown
that'll be 50 bucks thank you very much
yeah I think I think the crown you know
I think like obviously it's foremost in
my mind I
um I I think there's um
I think it's a wonderful show and
there's a lot less of it to watch than
the wire so I'd start with the crown
the the crown so I'm gonna say I'm I
made a TV show that not enough people
watched called Manhattan which was about
the Manhattan Project
and um please all spend your money go
and watch it it's informative and
Brilliant and beautifully written and
beautifully shot what's it all uh I
think you can buy it on Amazon it was
originally on WGN America
I and I'm actually gonna I don't mean to
talk about another show I watched every
episode of Manhattan for that and it was
spectacular I believe Sam Shaw was the
showrunner
um and I loved it it's it's a fantastic
show we're getting very restless people
from Netflix here can we bring it back
to the crown now please 100 what are the
things about the crown is that every
aspect of the show is just Spectacular
from the production design to the to
everything you know um uh and so I'm
curious for both of you what is it like
actually behind the scenes making the
show when you're working with just such
talented people in every Department
yeah it's amazing it's like settling
into the back of one of those amazing uh
1990s Bentleys that I get to drive
around and occasionally on this show I
mean it's very like that you get uh you
feel incredibly supported and and
surrounded by
extreme Prosperity that's like being
kidnapped by a very posh
crunch of gravel tells you you've
arrived at a stately home and then
there's a big top the way you go in and
come out looking like a member of the
royal family is lovely I'm curious for
both of you
um if you have a new appreciation or
look at the royal family
um after making the show and sort of
inhabiting these characters it you know
has it changed your your opinion or
perception you know what I mean about
the real thing like
yeah I mean many things have changed I
didn't really think about Charles much
before and
um one of the things is is is Josh
um O'Connor was very good at identifying
the fiddling that Charles does he's
always fiddling with his clothes
whenever he gets out the car he's always
doing this and and I noticed wearing
those clothes that if you want to look
Immaculate you have to fiddle the whole
time check your cuffs are like here that
your tires right up here that your your
little handkerchief is you know poking
out enough and so actually his what what
appeared to be nervous ticks or um I
discovered are are the only way that you
can do as he does which is look
Immaculate at all times so I I that was
one small thing another thing I noticed
and surprised me was how many people
he's met and and how um how that very
much defines his idea of the modern
monarchy that
um his role is to draw attention to the
needs of people Ordinary People of which
he's met more than probably anyone who's
ever lived except the queen
I think my Discovery was particularly in
the 90s that any photograph we have of
Camilla was taken by a man hidden in a
bush who was probably trespassing on her
property and if she looked hatchet-faced
and miserable that's because she either
didn't know she was being photographed
in the most unhappy time of her life or
she just realized there was a man in a
bush with a camera taking a picture of
her and what's been wonderful is to see
her emerge from that without being
vindictive without ever having Camilla
her story or some or some version of
events to put the record straight and
she's just emerged as a warm and
forgiving person who now Winks at the
Press who so tormented her yeah it's uh
for people that uh in America I don't
think they realize how brutal the
British press can be it's a different
level over there
yeah they're horrible
God bless them we love them yes thanks
guys no I mean it's crazy look before I
run out of time with you um I know you
guys are filming the final season
um and I'm just curious uh uh how has
that been going and uh because you know
it's the end of this great series
yeah well it's it's um
it's uh it's it's extraordinary because
of course it comes at the time after the
Queen's death when
um I suppose the crown has attracted
more criticism than probably before it's
also
um the most tumultuous season in many
ways and and it's also it covers the
time that most people remember since the
start of the show and so it's a very
exciting and
um daunting time to be doing this
material because uh you're you're aware
of the responsibility there are these
are people who are still alive and
that's an immense responsibility
Netflix is and and Peter Morgan are just
so at the top of our game now you've got
these extraordinary episodes like in
season five where you can have the
luxury of an episode about the romanovs
or an episode just about divorce it's
much more a philosophical show than uh
than just a sort of uh chronological
retelling can I steal five minutes of
your time or two seconds of your time to
say that today is World neuroendocrine
cancer awareness day and I've had
neuroendocrine cancer and Steve Jobs and
Aretha Franklin died of it and people
need to be more aware because uh
incidence has increased by 371 since the
90s is is that true yes
71 more common in the 2020s than it was
in the 1990s mostly because of now we
know how to diagnose it I I was going to
ask you if it's because people can
diagnose it or some is it something in
the air or like you know on four years
to diagnose me
Jesus I'm yes that no I'm so sorry
because I'm fine I'm here but it's that
just if you could put a word in for
pancreas for for neuroendocrine cancer
awareness I'd be very grateful I can
absolutely do that um and I'd be happy
to do that actually
um my last thing for you what um and I
just want to ask about Peter Morgan
because he's such a talented writer and
I'm just curious um what it's like
working with someone who clearly is so
gifted with his ability on the page yeah
he I mean what what's brilliant about
the way he writes this is that people
have said why have you got for example
the tampon gate scene and and he brings
it always back to everything has an
impact on the crown how that
conversation and it's being taped and
released to the Press impacted the crown
so every time there is something that
you question as why is this there just
look and think about how that had an
impact on the monarchy and it always
will be under an underlying truth that
it had an impact on the monarchy in this
country
um two things I think one one I was very
surprised how much you had an input that
you could change his mind you could uh
he would you could have a discussion
about lines and approaches which you
very much listened to and the second
thing
um
the second thing I think what's his
genius is his ability to find the story
The interesting story and he
encapsulated the other day in a press
conference when he said about the
marriage of Charles and Diana that what
interested him was it was the biggest
wedding of all time the most famous
wedding probably of all time uh that
much by more people than ever and
therefore this great great fairy tale
love love fairy tale
um which ended in a divorce court in
London where they were coupled 32 or 33.
and and I that I instantly saw you
instantly see the story there you see
the whole Arc and what's interesting
about it and that's his genius I think
is distilling it down to
around this whole mass of events that
for him was the interesting thing and
you could see why he's so good at uh at
coming up with the what's interesting in
in in in the crown
yeah that that's a great episode that
divorce thing um anyway listen congrats
on the show thank you so much for your
time good luck with the rest of your
speed dating thanks so much